[Music]
have you ever met someone who didn't
love Harry Potter with every fiber of
their being if so you probably called
them a muggle and distance yourself from
them and if we don't blame you after all
no one needs that kind of negativity in
their life stay tuned to find out why
Dumbledore isn't as innocent as he seems
to be let's jump right into the ten dark
Harry Potter theories that were actually
confirmed by JK Rowling a Wizards
lifespan have you ever wondered why
Professor Dumbledore looks like he was
about to topple over at any given moment
we sure have and we weren't alone in
doing so author JK Rowling has often
hinted that there are many differences
between wizards and muggles well it
turns out that their lifespan is one of
them while the average human can live up
to 80 years old the harry potter creator
revealed that wizards could actually
live for about 200 years at the time of
his death Dumbledore was about 150 years
old
so in short he actually could have lived
another 50 years on another note it was
Lord Voldemort's greatest desire to
become immortal however he died about
130 years prematurely if he had simply
refrained from putting himself in
precarious situations he might have
lived for centuries instead he chose to
split his soul apart in case someone
managed to take him down at the time
securing his soul into objects might
have made total sense but his plans sure
did fail poor Baldy if he only had made
some better life choices trouble in
paradise for Ron and Hermione many of us
were rooting for Ron and Hermione to
lock lips during the final Harry Potter
movie however some people weren't
exactly keen about the newfound
relationship when you think about it Ron
and Hermione are the least compatible
people in the world
Hermione is highly driven intelligent
and uptight whereas Ron is lazy a bit
slow and as loose as a goose
knowing this it's kind of hard to
believe that these two characters end up
together and JK Rowling agrees the
author has stated that her decision to
pair these two characters together had
everything to do with personal reasons
and not credibility sure they might not
have a world wind in common but
opposites attract right JK rowling also
revealed that Ron and Hermoine nice
relationship wouldn't always be filled
with gumdrops and lemon squares
in fact she mentioned that they would
meet many issues down the road and even
resort to muggle couples counseling to
fix them if you thought that Ron and
Hermione were a match made in heaven
we're very sorry to have burst your
bubble hold tight though because more
uneasy theories are coming your way
emotional scars it goes without saying
that war is never pretty sure sometimes
the good side can prevail but there is
no going back to the way things used to
be for this reason and many others
JK Rowling had a great deal of
difficulty writing the Battle of
Hogwarts since it is common for authors
to fall in love with their characters
one can only imagine how hard it was for
Rowling to kill them off in fact the
decision was so intense that she still
makes it a point to mention these
characters on their death anniversary
well enough about the ones who were lost
and let's switch to our focus to those
who were left behind hundreds of
students risk their lives for the
Wizarding World
during this epic battle according to
Rowling most of these students have
never been able to shake the fear and
sadness they felt that day these
feelings continue to follow these
characters to this very moment in fact
many of these characters named their
children after the ones who tragically
lost their lives during this battle in
the end some things are simply too big
to get over so long chunks and Remus
there is nothing easy about reading
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
especially since so many amazing
characters get killed off on May 2nd of
every year Rowling makes it a point to
apologize for killing Tonks and Lupin
during the Battle of Hogwarts
however she made it clear that she
simply had to there were many reasons
behind her decision but perhaps the
biggest one is that harry's loved ones
had to die since people like Ron
Hermione and a golden few were out of
the question
Rowling set her sights on the lupins
according to the author she was
struggling to choose between killing off
Arthur Weasley or Remus Lupin and she
chose the latter
keeping the Weasleys as whole as
possible was an obvious choice
especially since Fred was fated to
perish during this wicked battle the
author also commented on how fitting the
couple's death would be
in the end it was sort of like history
was repeating itself in this case Tonks
and Lupin resembled Lily and James
Potter respectively
it was also fitting that Harry would get
to raise an orphaned child however Harry
would never treat Teddy Lupin like the
Dursleys treated him the forever room
the fact that Harry had to grow up
without parents is absolutely
devastating however things could have
been worse Harry's mom and dad gave
their life to save their baby boy when
it comes to Neville Longbottom parents
though the same can be said
Neville also had to grow up without
parents but he did have the chance to
meet them just not in the heartwarming
way one might think Alice and Frank
Longbottom were good people who managed
to withstand being tortured by Bellatrix
Lestrange their will to keep their
secrets hidden cost them their sanity
though and it's something they were
never able to recover from many of us
were hopeful that never would one day be
able to talk to his mom and dad about
the brave acts he committed sadly never
we'll never be able to do so Rowling
confirmed that Frank and Alice would
always remain the same and that nothing
could ever change them since wizards and
witches can live for centuries they are
fated to remain at st. Mungo's hospital
of magical maladies until the day that
they pass over this is also applicable
to anyone who has suffered a memory
spell like our dear old professor
Lockhart in the end though we'd rather
he be locked up in the forever room
instead of Ron who he tried to obliviate
Dumbledore is gay Albus Dumbledore is
unlike any character in the Harry Potter
series his selfless nature and
charismatic ways have made it impossible
not to love him while he may be a
prominent figure in the Harry Potter
world there is little to be known about
his character sharor he's the headmaster
at Hogwarts and he's one of the best
wizards in the world but what about his
social life from what we know he's never
been married before nor has he had any
children of his own the only thing we do
know about him is that he has a brother
and had a sister once upon a time this
information was only spilled during
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows but
before that the man was a total mystery
while Roly might have described him as a
man with a twinkle in his eyes we never
once put two and two together
and realize that he was gay in the ends
who a person chooses to love doesn't
change anything but to say that we
weren't shocked about this revelation
would be a lie
when rollin confirms that Dumbledore was
in fact gay some of her fans were
outraged this only seemed to amuse the
hilarious author as a person or
character's sexual orientation shouldn't
make a difference in someone's life
never like these curtains set them on
fire in my fourth year by accident of
course Snape is gray Severus Snape was a
man of few words but when he spoke you
could be sure that nothing good was
about to be said he was crude rude and
severe despite being a teacher he found
little joy in helping his students
achieve greatness throughout the entire
Harry Potter series many of us grew up
to hate and mistrust Snape his
allegiance seemed to rely on what was
best for him in the moment regardless of
how things seemed to be it was later
revealed that Snape was in fact a good
guy and the best double agent we'd ever
seen after killing Dumbledore Snape was
seen as the big bad guy but in the end
he took no pleasure in murdering his
good friend when Harry finds out the
truth about snake he is practically
moved to tears so much so that he gives
his son his name it's easy to forget
that Snape was a bad guy considering how
much he gave up to save the Wizarding
World
but as Rowling has put it Snape is gray
by this she means that he is not black
or white but smacked down in the middle
his love for Lily Potter caused him to
reconsider his lifestyle but if it
hadn't been for that he might really
have enjoyed being a Death Eater
[Music]
the truth about purebloods one of the
most prestigious titles in the Wizarding
World is the one of pure blood those who
hold this title tend to believe that
they are better than everyone else with
the exception of the Weasleys of course
while having magical blood running
through your veins is seen as ideal
there are many amazing wizards and
witches who are half blooded or
muggle-born holding on to his sacred
bloodline isn't easy however especially
since pure blood families are scarce
with this in mind many pure blood
families tend to marry within their
circles which can have disastrous
effects did you know that Molly
Weasley's has some black in her family
tree if so you might have realized that
that makes her cousins with the Malfoy's
in the end the truth about the pure
Bloods is that their lineage is being
recycled due to not having enough to go
around it has often been said that if
wizards did not mate with muggles the
fate of the Wizarding World would have
taken a hit luckily a wizard's talents
can still be passed down on to muggle
bloodline they attend to people's teeth
and is that considered a dangerous
profession high school dropouts there's
a dark truth that many of us Harry
Potter fans never considered and this is
that Ron and Harry never actually
graduated from Hogwarts surely we all
knew that Hermione Ron and Harry were
skipping out on their last year at
Hogwarts to save the Wizarding World
this seemed out of character for
Hermione who was devoted to her
education like no one else in the end
though sacrifices had to be made after
the Battle of Hogwarts Hermione decided
to return to school and finish her last
year this makes her a Hogwarts graduate
unlike her life partner and best friend
Harry and Ron did not see the point in
going back to school they felt like they
had already graduated from that period
of their life Rowling confirmed that
these two buddies never received a
diploma however she also stated that
they didn't need one to get the jobs
they wanted in the end it isn't common
for dropouts to work at the Ministry of
Magic
but exceptions can be made for those who
deserve it does it bother you that these
two heroes never went back for their
diploma or do you think that they made
the right choice Dumbledore is death
when Rowling finished writing the last
Harry Potter book she knew that her fans
would come out with wild theories what
she didn't expect however was for one of
them to make
so much sense by now you're all familiar
with the tale of three brothers this
story is mentioned throughout the
deathly hallows plotline if you aren't
though allow us to fill you in a bit
when three brothers managed to cheat
death he granted them each a wish these
wishes gave birth to the Elder Wand the
resurrection stone and the cloak of
invisibility
when the brothers departed death
silently waited to claim their lives
however he was unable to claim the last
brother's life because he couldn't
locate him the fan theory behind the
story goes as follows
Voldemort is the first brother the one
who asks for the most powerful wand of
all time Snape is the second brother the
one who desperately wanted to bring his
lover back from the grave Harry is the
last brother the one who wanted to live
a beautiful life free from the fear of
death so where does that leave
Dumbledore
that's easy Dumbledore is actually death
himself and he waits for Harry to die
and grieve him like an old friends does
this make any sense to you we sure hope
so because it's Rowling approved which
dark theory was your favorite let us
know in the comments the Harry Potter
series used to be made for kids but
things got a little darker over the
years and we're not talking about the
story but about the actors - make sure
you watch this video until the end to
know which actor wanted to quit before
the end of the series if you got Harry
Potter as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 dark secrets in Harry Potter Warner
Brothers doesn't want you to know the
arrests have you ever wondered where did
vincent crabbe go he was supposed to
stay until the end and died in the last
movie but he suddenly disappeared out of
nowhere and was replaced by another
character in the movie series Warner
Brothers didn't want us to know what
happened but the news couldn't keep the
truth away from us
Jaime way let was driving in an Audi
when he was pulled over by the police
who thought he was behaving suspiciously
this is when they found eight bags of
weed in his car the actor and his friend
were taken to the police station then
his house was raided by the police and
this is where they found 10 mature
cannabis plants that were valued at
around 2000 euros or more than two
thousand seven hundred and fifty dollars
Jaime was arrested and fired from the
Harry Potter series but it look
like you didn't learn his lesson that's
because he was arrested a couple of
years later for his part in the London
riots in 2012 he received a two-year
sentence for violent disorder and 12
months for handling stolen goods however
he was eligible for release after one
year in prison
we haven't heard about him since these
events so we hope that he learned
something from this being famous and on
top of the world looks like a dream come
true but when you fall from that height
things can quickly turn out to be a
nightmare the second arrest he wasn't
the only Harry Potter actor who was
arrested and fired from the movie series
however you might not recognize this one
that's because it's the little man who
committed a big crime
Nicholas Reed was a dwarf who appeared
in the first Harry Potter movie as a
goblin he also played an Ewok in The
Return of the Jedi however he was not
the kind of person that kids should
watch that's because he was convicted of
indecent exposure after a seventeen year
old girl told police that he did
something really inappropriate under the
cover of a jugglers hat and that young
girl was certainly not interested in an
adult parody of Harry Potter while she
was sitting on a train that was not the
first time he did something weird
because he also clambered into the bed
of a stage manager and his girlfriend he
also made random and explicit phone
calls to women from a hotel room a few
years ago however Nicholas Reed was not
sentenced to spend some time in jail
because the judge thought that the
public would not benefit from him
receiving a short custodial sentence
this is why the actor was required to be
supervised by the probation service and
had to undertake a community offender
group work program to get rid of his bad
habit if you want to scare teenagers go
play a little monster in a horror movie
instead the addiction Jamie way that
loved illegal substances but another
actor was addicted to something a little
more legal but certainly not good at all
that's because Daniel Radcliffe the
actor who played Harry Potter turned out
to be an alcoholic while filming the
movie series it all started when he
turned 18 because the pressures of Fame
made him become dependent on alcohol and
as he had a very addictive personality
it wasn't hard for him to quickly become
alcoholic even those who never drink on
says the actor admitted that drinking
alcohol left him dead behind the eyes he
would black out nearly every time he
drank alcohol and this behavior was
becoming really destructive the act
not drinking at parties with his friends
like any other young man Daniel
Radcliffe said that he was so concerned
by his behavior in public that he
started drinking alone at home all by
himself even though the actor never
drank on set he admitted that he went to
work still drunk most alcoholics aren't
good at hiding the problems but Daniel
was bad when he watches the movie he can
even point to many scenes where he was
just gone no matter what we are happy to
see that alcohol is not a problem for
him anymore Daniel Radcliffe now says he
is not touching any alcohol anymore
because he wants to make sure that he
won't become alcoholic again the other
addiction another little incident
happened in 2009 and it involves some
illegal substances that's because some
pictures of Daniel Radcliffe partying
were shared all over the web he was
laughing because his friends drew a
beard on his face which is surprisingly
not very weird for young men like this
but what shocked the world was a picture
of Daniel Radcliffe smoking something
that really looks like weed it didn't
help when a party goer overhead the
actor saying that he loves weed the
title of The Daily Mirror even read
Harry pothead and we have to admit that
it was a really good pun but does that
mean that one of our favorite actors
isn't only an alcoholic but also is
addicted to illegal substances actually
many fans just said that they hoped he
doesn't end up with psychosis and that
smoking with moderation won't kill
anyone after all he's just an actor and
he should have the right to do whatever
he wants with his life even though it's
not always recommended weed is becoming
legal in more and more countries
nowadays but if you do care you
shouldn't worry about this one this time
the actor categorically denied smoking
anything like that actually his
spokesman said that Daniel does smoke
the occasional roll-up cigarette but he
is not doing anything more than s anyway
he won't be the first young man to make
a mistake and the whole world doesn't
have to know about it the biggest fans
however there are some things that
Daniel Radcliffe actually did during a
party we're not saying it's bad we're
not saying it's good but we would never
expect Harry Potter to do this that's
because the actor admitted that he used
to get lucky with groupies he explained
that he was drinking but that doesn't
make anything better
however he has always been very nervous
about the groupie thing he likes to like
someone before being intimate with them
that's
because he knows that he's going to have
to talk to them afterward even if it
only lasts one night they know himself
admitted that he was terrible the whole
dating thing he said that he was not an
easy person to love there are lots of
times when he's a good boyfriend but
there are times when he's useless and
he's also a mess around the house he
talks non-stop and gets obsessed with
things but no matter what what he likes
the most is having a girlfriend in 2012
he was dating Rosie Coker a production
assistant who worked on the Harry Potter
movies he didn't see her a lot because
he was always working but no matter what
he said that everyday seemed to get
better when he was with Rosie and he had
someone in his life who made him happier
than he ever thought he could be we
think that this makes us happier than
being one of his lucky groupies the
affair daniel radcliffe is not the only
one who thinks that dating is hard there
is also a love triangle or actually a
hate triangle on the set of Harry Potter
it involved in the Thompson who play a
professor Trelawney Kenneth Branagh
who plays professor Gilderoy Lockhart
and Helena Bonham Carter who played
Bellatrix Lestrange Emma and Kenneth had
been married for six years
unfortunately they filed for divorce
when the actress learned that her
husband was having an affair the problem
was that he was secretly dating Helena
this new relationship lasted for five
years before they finally split up and
Helena ended up with Tim Burton that's
already a terrible thing to go through
but things got really awkward when the
three actors started working on set
together and my finally spoke out about
it for the first time in 2013 she said
that it was all blood under the bridge
and added that you can hold on to
anything like that according to her it
is pointless and they haven't got the
energy for that anyway the two actresses
made peace years and years ago and we
are really happy to see that there was
actually no problem on set we can't
imagine how hard it would be to work
with your ex-husband and the woman that
he had been dating no matter what the
two women seemed happier about Kenneth
so we can say that everything happens
for a reason
the nudity so we know who got intimate
with who but Daniel Radcliffe got a
little intimate with a lot of people
when he worked as an actor don't worry
he wasn't drunk with a groupie this time
it was actually part of the performance
he first shocked the world during a play
called Equus people were impressed to
see that he looks nothing like Harry
Potter and
really did have potential as an actor
but anyone who saw the play will
remember the prolonged scene that
involved full frontal nudity they saw
Harry Potter naked actually they aren't
even sure that was the guy who played
Harry Potter he looked so different but
Daniel Radcliffe didn't really care
about this he said that it never really
was an issue actually he didn't even
know why the actor thinks that it should
have been because he is terribly
self-conscious according to him the
emotional nakedness was more daunting
and just to make sure that we won't
associate him with Harry Potter again
the actor took off his wizard robe for
another role and kill your darlings you
can't get enough of this he stripped
once again in 2017 in the movie jungle
come on Daniel isn't it getting cold out
there we're pretty sure that Warner
Brothers wants to make sure that no kid
knows about this all grown-ups will
watch the movie as if they want to the
agent just because you keep your clothes
on doesn't mean that you are a role
model you're not talking about talent
but about professionalism
you probably remember Devon Murray who
played Simas Finnegan in the movie
franchise that was probably one of the
best roles of his entire career so far
and he made a lot of money with that
actually he almost made around 1 million
dollars while he was just a kid and
wasn't even one of the main characters
but the problem was that he never paid
the agents who gave him this role
usually actors are supposed to give
around 15% of the money they make to
their agent to thank them for giving
them this role but Devon forgot to do
that after a little incident his mother
said that his agent failed to protect
the star against bad publicity when
people saw pictures of him smoking on
set she claims that her son had gone out
drinking took out girls and bought cars
because that is what teenage boys do and
she thought that her agent was
responsible for the fact that he had a
bad reputation anyway the agent sued the
actor and Devon was forced to give him
260 thousand euros
we're sorry Devon but we think that you
deserve this you wouldn't have gotten
this role without your agent and he
deserves money to the deaths you
probably already heard that Richard
Harris who played the first Dumbledore
passed away while filming the movie
series and was replaced by a Michael
Gambon it was
a big surprise because he was actually
very old but he was so young in his
heart that we thought he would last
forever we will always remember the day
when Alan Rickman who played Severus
Snape passed away it was hard enough to
see him go in the movie and we were not
ready to say goodbye to him in real life
these are both tragic deaths that made
us feel like we have lost some of our
childhood friends but there are actually
many actors from Harry Potter who
recently died John Hurt who played
Ollivander in the movie series passed
away in January 2017
he died of pancreatic cancer just like
Alan
there is also Dave Logano who plays
Fenrir Greyback who passed away in 2014
he was found dead in Death Valley in
California after suffering from a heart
stroke and we won't forget about many
other actors who left us like Robert
Knox Rick may Hall Alpha Burke
Christopher Winningham Timothy Bateson
Terrance Baylor Peter Cartwright Derrick
Dedmon and more but there are actually
other reasons why some actors wanted to
leave the Harry Potter world the missing
actress the Harry Potter series would
have never been the same if this actress
decided to quit acting at that time do
you know who it was we can't believe
that in the watson who plays Hermione
Granger didn't want to be part of the
movie series anymore and the problem was
that she was a little too much like
Hermione Granger herself that's because
she wanted to quit this project because
education was more important for her
unfortunately with such a busy schedule
it was really hard for her to pursue her
studies she fought hard to make sure
that she would be able to go to
university and sit her a levels because
the schedule for the movies was just
crazy
can you imagine Harry Potter without the
one and only Hermione Granger Emma said
that she would have been public enemy
number one if she hadn't continued she
did think about that this is why the
filmmakers decided to do a little
something to make sure that she would
still be part of the team they moved the
Harry Potter film schedule around her
exam dates and this is how it all worked
out the actress was very grateful for
this and we are even more grateful to
see that we had the chance to keep our
favourite Hermione which of these 10
dark secrets surprised you the most
don't be shy to answer in the comment
section down below we'd love to hear
what you think we have found eight
mind-blowing Harry Potter theories that
will make you rethink everything stay
tuned to find out the truth about
Hermione Granger's parents
you've got dirt on your nose by the way
did you know Neville's wand Neville has
99 problems and a wand is definitely one
of them when we first met Neville
Longbottom in the books he is described
as a totally inept wizard in fact his
family thought he was a squib for a long
time then his uncle launched him out of
a window and Neville bounced
yikes Neville struggles with a lot of
things like remembering his robes and
everything to do with potions and he is
really bad at casting spells but Neville
is amazing at herbology but after book 5
Neville really starts to improve as a
wizard he gets more confidence and his
magical skills improve in the deathly
hallows
neville leads the student resistance at
hogwarts against the evil cairo twins
he fights bravely at the Battle of
Hogwarts and let's not forget that he's
the one that kills Nagini
the final Horcrux so why the sudden
change in Neville this fan theory
suggests that Neville's wand is the
reason for most of his problems
this theory goes all the way back to
2004 from an old I'm grrrrrr post user
soggy toots points out that Neville's
wand was actually his dad's that's right
the wand that he uses belongs to the
hero Aurora Frank Longbottom sure
Neville is insecure but the wand chooses
the wizard right this one chose Frank
not Neville of course Neville would have
trouble casting with this wand Neville's
wand breaks the battle at the Department
of mysteries in the order of the Phoenix
he gets a new wand presumably from
Ollivanders and this wand chooses
Neville that explains why he's suddenly
way better at magic MARY POPPINS is a
witch we are heading into crossover
territory now the Harry Potter world is
full of amazing witches and wizards have
you ever wondered if some of your other
favorite characters were actually from
the same world there are a ton of fan
theories out there about Mary Poppins
including that she is a Time Lord from
the world of Doctor Who but reddit user
big see big suggests that Mary Poppins
was actually a witch in the Harry Potter
universe and she wasn't just any witch
she was an important witch who works for
the Ministry of Magic this theory
suggests that Mary Poppins was of course
a ravenclaw after Hogwarts she got a job
at the ministry she was responsible for
investigating muggle-born witches and
wizards and also
introducing them to the world of magic
the evidence is totally there her bag
definitely has an undetectable extension
charm on it just like Hermione's purse
and she teaches the kids to keep their
magic a secret this theory also stay
said Bert was a squib which is why he
knew all about magic but couldn't
perform it and then this theory takes a
dark turn
where was Mary Poppins when Harry was
growing up well Mary loved muggles and
muggle-borns she lived with them all the
time after all it is likely that she was
a victim of Voldemort in the first
Wizarding war we know he wanted to get
rid of all muggle-borns sympathizers and
Mary Poppins would definitely have been
outspoken in her support Weasley Wonka
the twins Fred and George Weasley are
fan favorites these two talented wizards
are always up for a good time they cause
a lot of trouble but then they put their
skills to good use they open a
successful joke store called Weasleys
Wizard wheezes there are all sorts of
cool products including candies that can
make you sick enough to get out of class
in fact a lot of their products come in
the form of candies can you think of
another famous magical person who made
candy that's right Willy Wonka Willy
Wonka is totally eccentric he has a
factory in London with weird creatures
the Oompa Loompas in the book Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory
we learned that Willy Wonka is a rags to
riches story what if George Weasley
adopted the persona of Willy Wonka after
Fred died at the Battle of Hogwarts he
would be so sad about losing his twin
that adopting a new life would feel like
a good idea
Willy where his eccentric clothes and a
top hat the figure outside the Weasleys
store wears a top hat though balloon
puss are similar to house elves George
loses an ear and deathly hallows in
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
Willie tells Charlie he's a bit deaf in
one ear
Willy also gives his store to a muggle
named Charlie George like his father
author loved muggles do you think Willy
Wonka is actually George Weasley we
think there is some really compelling
evidence in this theory King Harry
her final crossover theory requires a
bit of knowledge about authoring legends
and this is one long detailed theory
from four emotions they
basically this theory suggests that
Harry is actually King Arthur rightful
king of the Britons a lot of this has to
do with hints from JK Rowling that
Gryffindor is a house of royalty the
Weasleys mostly have names of actual
British Kings also in the Harry Potter
world Merlin is a very real person
Harry pulled the Sword of Gryffindor
from a hat so did Neville just like
Arthur pulled a magic sword from a stone
in other author's stories the sword lies
on the bottom of the lake where is the
Sword of Gryffindor in the Deathly
Hallows that's right it's on the bottom
of a lake
Harry defeats a dragon which makes him
the pin dragon that's another name for
King Arthur there is also the fact that
Holly is associated with Kings Harry's
wand is made from Holly also there are a
lot of important cups in Harry Potter
there is the house cup the Quidditch Cup
the Quidditch World Cup the Goblet of
Fire and the Triwizard Cup King Arthur's
best known story is about the hunts for
another important Cup the Holy Grail
basically this theory suggests that not
only is Harry a direct descendant of
King Arthur but that he's a reincarnated
Arthur the myths always say King Arthur
will return when Britain needs him most
well Harry Potter does save the world
from the worst wizard ever tell me what
exactly is the function of a rubber duck
JK Skeeter if all these crossover
theories are true then that means one
thing the world of Harry Potter is real
we've all wished that this world is real
for a long time we're convinced our
Hogwarts letters got lost in the mail as
you can't convince us otherwise so if
there really are witches and wizards
among us how do we know so much about
them there are plenty of people out
there who think that JK Rowling is just
a pen name for a very famous witch Rita
Skeeter herself both Rita and JK are
blond and they both know a lot about
this magical world as an unregistered
animagus Rita would know all the tiny
little details that we see in the books
it's generally accepted that after the
Battle of Hogwarts Rita Skeeter lost her
credibility some theory suggests that
she was even banished from the magical
world well how would a writer make money
in a new world
they say writers should write what they
know Rita Skeeter under the name JK
Rowling wrote about the boy who lives
marketed it as a fiction to mughals
mughals don't believe it's real so she's
not in any real danger of violating the
statute of secrecy now we aren't saying
that a muggle wouldn't be smart enough
to create such a detailed magical world
but we would much prefer it if Hogwarts
and all the other magical places were
real Rita Skeeter has been pretty
skilled at writing fiction her whole
career even though she was supposed to
be writing facts Harry and the Dementors
Dementors are one of the creepiest
creatures in the Harry Potter books
these dark faceless creatures literally
suck out all of the happiness in your
soul that's pretty much the worst fate
ever in the books Harry is extra
affected by the Dementors he hears
screaming and passes out
Dementors make everyone feel pretty
miserable but why is Harry so affected
by their presence
he even passes out when he is way up on
his broom stick and the Dementors are on
the ground supposedly it's because Harry
free lives the night his parents pelts
of all des morts but Harry isn't the
only wizard to experience horrible
tragedy why doesn't everyone who has
seen awful things react as Harry does
also Harry was just over a year old when
his parents were killed if there's been
a theory going around for years about
this it's not that Harry has a terrible
memory when the Dementors are around
it's because he isn't Horcrux
the Dementors are drawn to Harry because
they can sense that he has an extra soul
inside of him and the memory he relives
is actually baltimore its worst memory
so when the Dementors are around there
are two souls inside of Harry reacting
to them we wonder if Harry had an easier
time around Dementors after the Horcrux
inside him was defeated diagonally the
sorting hat secret you know how it
happens the first years are taken to
Hogwarts by small boats across the Black
Lake they are ushered into the Great
Hall where they see a raggedy old hat
sitting on a stool the Hat starts to
sing it spends all gear creating a new
song about Hogwarts and its founders
then one by one each student is called
up to sit on the stool the sorting hat
reads their minds and decides which
house they belong in we know Ron doesn't
know how the sorting will happen that he
has had five siblings go to Hogwarts
before him in fact most of the students
have family members who went to Hogwarts
why are they all
shocked by the sorting hat this plot
hole was pointed out by ben karlin from
the super carl in brothers how is such a
huge secrets kept from all these young
witches and wizards the only logical
explanation is that the sorting hat is
under a fidelia's charm if you remember
in the order of the Phoenix this is the
charm that requires a secret keeper
only the secret keeper can reveal the
truth to people who don't know it but
once you are in on the secret you can
talk about it to others who know number
12 Grimmauld place is under the
fidelia's charm and Dumbledore is the
secret keeper harry's childhood home was
also under the fidelia's charm Peter
Pettigrew was the secret keeper and he
told Baltimore where it was so who is
the Hatt's secret keeper
it's either McGonigle who leads the
sorting ceremony or it's the Hat itself
what happened to the grinders one of the
saddest moments in the Deathly Hallows
is when we learn about Hermione's major
sacrifice to save her parents hermione
knows at baltimore to end the Death
Eaters are going after muggle-borns and
their families she obliviate sure
parents removing all memories of their
only daughter she convinces them that
they are other people who have always
wanted to go to Australia in the movie
Deathly Hallows Part 1 we actually see
her mind and cast the charm but in the
books she just tells Harry what she has
done
tumblr users savers thinks that she
actually performs the memory charm of
much sooner in fact they think she did
it as early as their fourth year
hermione knows that Voldemort is gaining
power because she's friends with Harry
at the Quidditch World Cup she sees
exactly how Death Eaters treat muggles
she would be really worried about her
parents during this time she is smart
she knows another war is coming after
her fourth year she never goes home
again she always spends her summers at
the Weasleys also when she has Madame
Pomfrey shrinker teeth back to a normal
size
she doesn't even worry about what her
dentist parents will say their
buck-toothed child is magically not
buck-toothed anymore that's because her
parents are long gone as just a young
teenager hermione sacrificed having
loving parents to keep them alive
no wonder hermione was sorted into
Gryffindor instead of Ravenclaw
do you know any epic Harry Potter
theories let us know in the comments
we hope you don't have to make a trip to
st. among
goes hospital for magical maladies after
these mind-blowing theories
Hogwarts will always be there to welcome
you home and so will these amazing Harry
Potter theories seriously you're not
ready to hear about Fred and George's
secret power don't forget to subscribe
to the things and give this video a
thumbs up if you love Harry Potter now
let's check out 10 Dark theories about
Harry Potter that will change everything
class size let's start with a few
theories that aren't known that well but
they actually seem pretty believable in
one of our interviews
JK Rowling said they're about a thousand
students at Hogwarts but have you ever
noticed that in the movie as well as in
the books
Harry's year is pretty small the movies
show about eighteen students in Harry's
year and the books rarely mentioned
anyone else besides the people you
already know it doesn't add up if you
think Hogwarts supposed to have
thousands of students a tumblr user
marauders forever came up with the most
amazing theory ever and it's kind of sad
- we know Voldemort was at the reign of
power between 1979 and 1981 which would
have been the years when Harry's class
would be born there's a connection
between all those facts if you think
about it when Voldemort was at the reign
of power not a lot of people survived
and since he reigned during the time
when Harry's class would have been born
this tumblr user assumes that this is
exactly why his class was so small it's
a pretty dark theory but it definitely
would make sense right the cursed job we
all know that Defense Against the Dark
Arts was a cursed job position but it
was never really explained why we also
know that the curse tried to be lifted
by Albus Dumbledore himself but he
wasn't able to a Reddit user has an
interesting theory on why that might be
the case the curse on the position
started from the moment Dumbledore
refused the job - Voldemort and we've
also seen Voldemort hide his diadem
Horcrux in the room of the requirement
the entrance and the exit of the room of
the requirement could be placed anywhere
like we've seen it in the last book
where the students avoid the Carrows
this redditor thinks that Voldemort
requirement when hiding the diadem
involved the defense against the dark
arts position to be cursed his soul was
anchored to one of the most magical
parts of the castle and acted as a fuel
the curse the redditor also adds that JK
rowling actually confirmed that the
curse was lifted following Voldemort's
passing and the destruction of the
diadem so it's safe to say there's
definitely some truth to the fact that
Voldemort really did try to make sure no
other person could become the Defense
Against the Dark Arts professor for too
long the Dursleys are innocent this is a
popular theory and there actually might
be some truth to it it also ties into
Voldemort's Horcruxes which as we
discovered changed how we see the story
completely but these theories change
them again so this popular fan theory
states that the Dursleys weren't
actually as mean as they seem to be
let's remember that petunia was forced
to take Harry in what's his parents
passed away but since Voldemort made
Harry an accidental Horcrux it means
that whoever's nearby him could
potentially feel the negative effects
Horcruxes have we saw this worked very
well in Duk Lee Hallows but what if
Harry as a Horcrux had this effect on
the Dursleys
what if they actually behaved this way
because of the Horcrux of course this
theory shouldn't excuse abuse Harry
endured in any way Daniel Radcliffe
actually shared his sentiments on this
theory and said that the Dursleys would
have been quite a different family
without Harry he did say that he felt
like the Dursleys just really hated
having Harry around but that this is a
pretty cool theory of course petunias
bitterness also came from the fact that
she never got to be a witch like her
sister so who knows if things would
actually change if Harry wasn't a
Horcrux
um bridges locket Umbridge is probably
one of the most hated characters in the
entire Harry Potter series Harry Potter
fans have a theory about the slytherins
locket which turned out to be one of
Voldemort's Horcruxes we told you the
entire Harry Potter story really changes
once you start theorizing on the
creation of the Horcruxes this theory is
similar to the theory about Dursleys but
it's still pretty interesting we all
know that Umbridge was wearing Salazar
Slytherin's locket and that she was
totally evil when she was do you see
where we're going with this so what if
the Horcrux had an extra effect on her -
when you combine it with the fact that
the defense against the dark arts
position was cursed because of another
Horcrux and the fact that Harry was
another one
it can mean that Umbridge was just
simply under the power of too many
Horcruxes JK rally actually responded to
these theories and stated that while the
Horcruxes would have definitely added to
her existing evil demeanor umbrage was
in fact evil on her own - to be fair
were kind of relieved because the last
thing we want to have is sympathy for
Dolores Umbridge after life there are a
couple of Harry Potter theories out
there about the afterlife that actually
seem pretty believable
we'll discuss one more later on but
let's check out one right now one of
these theories focuses on Hedwig
everyone's favorite pet owl a redditor
stated that Hedwig could actually be
Lily Potter this reddit user states that
Hedwig always seemed extremely
protective of Harry and knew what was
happening at all times she was far too
intelligent and apathetic the redditor
also states that Hedwig would comfort
Harry even during the time he would stay
at the Dursleys the user also theorizes
that Lily Potter's Petronas would
definitely be a snowy owl do you see
where we're going with this another
editor also claimed that Hedwig's
passing came immediately after Harry's
seventeenth birthday which would be the
age when the protection spell from his
childhood would have worn off some even
state that Hedwig was actually a reverse
Horcrux and when Lily passed a part of
her soul became Hedwig although the last
theory makes less sense we can
definitely see how Lily's spirit could
live on in Hedwig after all she was
definitely the best had a person could
ask for wasn't she Snape's alive
Snape's entire character is a big fan
theory that actually came true if you
think about it he definitely had one of
the best Redemption stories ever some
fans seem to think that Snape is still
alive and they have a couple of points
to share a Reddit user came up with some
pretty impressive evidence to support
this theory and the first one comes from
the fact that Snape doesn't appear
during the summoning with the
resurrection stone Snape would have been
very important to Harry but yet he
didn't appear with the stone even if
Lupin did and another piece of evidence
states that snake's body was nowhere to
be found after the Battle of Hogwarts
all other bodies were laid out on the
floor the snake's body wasn't there at
all and you'd think a skilled potions
professor could save himself from Nagini
Spang poison right
Snape was the master at potions but he
couldn't find an antidote he was a spy
after all he seemed to have a lot of
trust in Nagini because we'd definitely
make sure she wouldn't be able to attack
us so could it be that he's still alive
after all or is that just wishful
thinking Albus Dumbledore and Slytherin
here's another theory this one connects
Dumbledore to Salazar Slytherin and
while it might be one of the lesser
known theories it's definitely still
interesting some of this information
comes from fantastic beasts where you
can definitely learn some backstories on
a few characters we learn about assaults
a er a Slytherin descendant who had two
daughters that understood Parseltongue
and we all know Dumbledore seems to
understand Parseltongue perfectly well
and JK Rowling even implied that you can
only be born with the Parseltongue
knowledge there's no way anyone would be
able to just pick up Parseltongue and
learn it and we all know that Ron's
attempt was just pure luck so how is
Dumbledore able to understand
Parseltongue been and how does this
connect to Salazar Slytherin in Deathly
Hallows we learn a thing or two about
Dumbledore's mother Kendra including
that she looks like a Native American
this relates to the fact that assaults
Squibb daughter Martha actually married
a Native American man the theory states
that Kendra is actually related to
Martha as she seems to have Native
American features herself which also
means that Dumbledore is related to
assault ser who's a Slytherin descendant
what do you think believable mechanicals
secret okay this next theory is pretty
dark actually it's by far one of the
darkest theories we're sharing today and
it will definitely change your
perspective on McGonagall she might be
everyone's favorite character but you
might change your mind after you hear
this story if there's one thing Harry
Potter fans want more than anything is
that Harry was never left with the
Dursleys
they were absolutely terrible but what's
even worse is the fact that McGonagall
knew this all along she even warned
Dumbledore and said they were the worst
type of muggles
but it seems that she never even wanted
to check on Harry after dropping him off
Miss fig didn't stop the abuse either
though McGonagall had to know what Harry
went through since his first Hogwarts
letter was addressed to the cupboard
under
the stairs the letters changed based on
Harry's location the mechanical must
have had a clear idea what Harry was
going through and yet she never wanted
to intervene or help fan theories state
that she might not be so innocent after
all the truth is she really didn't want
to help Harry as much as she looked like
she did so much for being a motherly
character the truth about Cruikshank's
this is one of our favorite fan theories
and despite the logical flaw which we'll
mention in a little bit it does seem the
most believable
we've all met Cruikshank's but this
furry cat also holds a lot of mystery to
it in fact there's not a lot that's
known about his origin van seemed a
state that Hermione wasn't the cat's
first owner considering she bought him
from a pet shop and the sales which said
that he's been there for ages and no one
wanted him we also know that the Potters
did actually have a cat because Harry
found his mother's letter in Deathly
Hallows the letter stated that Harry
almost hurt the cat while on his toy
broomstick and he even wondered what
happened to the cat so what if
Crookshanks actually belonged to the
Potters before Hermione got him maybe
someone found the cat and the magical
menagerie took him in after he was left
without his original owners seems pretty
believable right the one big flaw with
this theory is that Sirius would have
definitely known Crookshanks since he
was friends with the Potters he even
said that he had to gain the cat's trust
at some point but who knows maybe they
got Crookshanks after Sirius was sent to
Azkaban Fred and George switching bodies
one thing that's not explored enough in
Harry Potter are twins it seems strange
that twins wouldn't have any extra
powers or any other magical Inklings
right a theory states that Fred and
George were actually interchangeable and
could switch bodies whenever they wanted
Molly and Arthur even worried when Fred
and George weren't really doing any
accidental magic as kids but we all know
that could never be the case so what if
they were really switching bodies all
this time and no one even noticed the
theory states that Fred and George
learned to act like each other ever
since they were kids which is one of the
reasons why they can finish each other's
sentences they just know each other that
well from keeping their grades up to
keeping each other awake in class they
were switching bodies to help each other
in life soon their trick is discovered
by Lee
and later several other people that just
get to know them really well the theory
goes as far to state that this goes on
after Fred passes the to continue to
switch bodies until it's George's time
to join Fred at the Kings Cross station
a theory and a fanfiction who really
need this to happen Harry Potter might
be over but fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald brought us back to
researching Harry Potter theories we
might have missed stay tuned to hear
about an awesome theory about Nagini
that has nothing to do with the zoo from
the first book don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to the
things now let's check out ten Harry
Potter fan theories that changed
everything
true Lonnie's prediction let's start off
with the character no one really liked
but she turned out to make quite a few
predictions that ended up coming true
let's face it we all thought her Lonnie
was just a con artist until we learned
that JK Rowling never coincidentally
write something and everything connects
this one is a simple theory but it
should really change your opinion on the
divination professor do you remember the
very first divination class where
professor Trelawney tries to guess
Harry's birth month and gets it wrong
which makes people around chuckle well
one Cora writer pointed out that she
actually kind of was right now that we
know that Harry is a Horcrux she's
saying that Harry was born in midwinter
but we all know that he was born in July
well what if she was actually guessing
the age of his Horcrux or even
Voldemort's birthday we also know that
Tom Riddle aka Voldemort was born on
December 31st which is still considered
midwinter sure Lonnie did actually
foreshadow Harry being a Horcrux except
no one ever realized it knowing that we
were feeling there are plenty of more
hints thrown our way as we reread the
book speaking of we bet you never saw
this hint coming the Dursleys
sure Lonnie's theory kind of connects to
this one so we all know that Harry's a
Horcrux and because of the last book we
also know that whoever's around a
Horcrux becomes miserable and can even
start picking fights a tumblr user
called graphic nerd
pointed out an interesting theory that
will make you look at the Dursleys in a
completely different light we all know
the Dursleys were completely mean and
abusive to Harry without any reason
whatsoever other than they really hated
the magic fool but what if their
behavior relates to the fact that they
were living with a Horcrux all this time
of course some people might say that
this theory might just want to make
excuses for Dursleys behavior and blame
Harry but could it be that their mood
was also magnified by the fact that
Harry was a Horcrux the theory was never
confirmed by JK Rowling and although it
might be accidental it does put things
in a weird perspective and definitely
changes everything
well everything except for the fact that
the Dursleys were just unapologetically
mean to Harry for all those years what
do you think of this one let us know in
the comments foreshadowing this fan
theory from a quarry user states that
the very first book had a lot of
foreshadowing in what's going to happen
in the end and the main link is Forenza
the Centaur who rescued Harry from the
very first Voldemort sighting the
Centaurs are mad at Forenza for
interfering and say that it's written in
the stars a statement that is also later
confirmed by Harry we also know that in
the very final book when the battle
between Harry and Voldemort happened yet
again the Centaurs did nothing to help
and finally allowed the stars to do what
it was said in the prophecy they only
joined the battle once the news that
Harry had lost his life was being spread
the fan theory states that the sentence
it was written in the stars for shadows
what was meant to happen between Harry
and Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest
all along and we all know that Forenza
was banished from the herd for
interfering as well as helping
Dumbledore - plus it makes sense why
centaurs took a step back until the
prophecy was fulfilled another
foreshadowing from the first movie
occurs when Hagrid talks about
you-know-who and his whereabouts he
states that he doesn't believe he's
actually gone because he doesn't think
he had enough human left in him creavy's
parents now this is an interesting one a
reddit user pointed out a possible
reason why Colin Creevey
parents are both muggles we all know
that both Colin and his brother are
wizards which is kind of strange
considering they were both muggles
there's no way two muggles would be able
to give birth to two wizards right well
luna Lilliputians theory states that
their parents weren't actually muggles
they were squids actually given up by
pure blood families the user goes on to
say that their families put them up for
adoption and wipe their children's
memories because they were so
disappointed in them for not being able
to produce magic so they grew up in a
normal muggle environment and they never
remembered their magic past at all we
also know that Colin's dad loves looking
at pictures of Hogwarts which could mean
he's actually trying to touch on a
memory that's been erased
hallucinations this is a pretty popular
theory but it really does change the way
we see the entire story
it states that Harry simply imagined and
hallucinating the entire thing the
theory states that harry's an abused
child who's also pretty much emotionally
neglected we've seen how the Dursleys
treat him and how excited he was every
time he got a Christmas present and
remember the moment when Hagrid rescued
Harry from the Dursleys psychologists
taissa this is known as fantasy coping
victims of abuse are known to create
alternate realities in order to cope
with the abuse they're facing but this
theory gets even more surreal it states
that the abuse can also be seen in the
so called Hogwarts hospital
Harry's friends usually get treated for
far less serious things but he seems to
get broken arms cracked skulls and he's
constantly in for life-threatening
situations so could it be that Harry has
actually subconsciously created this
magical world but he's actually still
living in the cupboard under the stairs
it's a scary thought especially if you
think about how many times he ended up
in that hospital childhood definitely
ruins the other chosen one so we all
know Harry and Neville have a lot of
things in common but one thing that
always bugs fans is the unexplainable
reason why Neville's broomstick was
acting strange during his first flying
lesson
the explanation is pretty simple Neville
is clumsy and he kicked his feet off the
ground before Madame hooch blew the
whistle well at least in the books
because he kicks off after the whistle
blow in the movies because Neville
didn't know how to fly a broomstick just
yet
went out of control but this theory
states that it's not just Neville's
clumsiness that made the broomstick go
crazy according to some fans it was
quirrell's fault we all have seen curl B
which Harry's broom during Quidditch but
we also know he's read the prophecy and
at that time it wasn't clear whether
Neville or Harry was the chosen one so
what if Quirrell was the one that
actually jinxed Neville's broomstick and
then used the exact same trick on Harry
if coral was really responsible for the
broomstick accident Neville was pretty
lucky that all he got was a broken wrist
imagine the story without Neville
although this theory was never confirmed
it's pretty believable a werewolf this
theory is all about Draco Malfoy the
entire theory can be found at Draco
Malfoy is a werewolf calm and we bet
you've already guessed what this theory
is about by now according to some fans
Draco is actually a werewolf there are
plenty of statements that support this
theory including the fact that in the
actual books we never see Draco's dark
mark that would indicate he's actually a
part of Voldemort's crew we also know
that Fenrir Greyback a bloodthirsty
werewolf was actually a family friend we
also see Draco looking sickly in Harry
Potter and the half-blood Prince
according to this theory is because spin
rear actually bit Draco as a punishment
for Lucius Malfoy repeated failures and
of course then there's the fact that
Narcissa Malfoy a devoted Voldemort
supporter turned on him at the final
moments the theorist states that this
made no sense unless someone she loved
was no longer welcome in the pure blood
order and her love for Draco was
stronger than her loyalty to Voldemort's
this theory would definitely change a
few things however it turned out to be
false when Pottermore finally released
more backstory about Draco and how he
indeed was a Death Eater and not a
werewolf immortal seriously this theory
is pretty impressive remember the
prophecy where Trelawney states that
neither Harry nor Voldemort can live
while the other survives we all just
assumed that Harry is just destined to
be destroyed by Voldemort
but I'm Gore user HP Wombats interpreted
the prophecy in another way if either
Harry or Voldemort can't really survive
at the hands of the
other that means that the one to survive
is actually immortal as a result too so
yes Harry could be immortal but there's
an even darker part to this theory we
always see Harry's parents present in
the final series it's clearly seen that
there is an afterlife available for
Harry where he'd be reunited with his
parents but if this theory is true and
if Harry is in fact immortal it means
that he actually sacrificed his death
for Valda mort's passing which also
means that he will never ever have the
opportunity to see his family or any
loved ones that have passed in afterlife
and considering he doesn't even have the
Elder Wand
since he broke it he's pretty much stuck
being alive whether he likes it or not
now that's a theory that will really
ruin your childhood Harry and Jenny
Harry and Ginny were probably one of the
most unusual couples ever despite the
fact that Ginny had a crush on Harry
long before he noticed that she's
anything more than Ron's sister that's
precisely what this theory is about as
much as people seem to have loved Harry
and Ginny and they did turn out to be
the endgame some fans seem to think that
Ginny administered a love potion to
Harry if you think about it Harry was
always indifferent to Ginny but
everything changed in the half-blood
prince part of the series we've seen
Romilda vane use a love potion before
Anne's Moreau Gaunt's also used this
technique to make Tom Riddle fall in
love with her so could it be that this
was the reason why Harry suddenly
started taking interest in Ginny if you
remember JK Rowling described it as a
roaring creature inside of Harry but
isn't it strange how Harry never even
noticed Ginny in a romantic way before
this imagine if Ginny actually did use a
love potion to make Harry fall in love
with her this would have definitely
turned things around and we're really
not sure we'll ever be ready for this
theory to be true Ron is Dumbledore one
of the weirdest but probably most common
Harry Potter theories out there is the
one where Ron is actually a
time-traveling Dumbledore this theory is
old like 2004 old the theory first came
out from the Wizards chess scene in the
very first Harry Potter series where Ron
plays as a knight and the king that's
exactly what Dumbledore is in the
greater Wizarding war to
humm according to the theory Ron and
Dumbledore share a lot of similarities
including one where Dumbledore's
Christmas wish is a pair of warm socks
and of course let's not forget about the
fact that Dumbledore left Iran with a
really unexpected item after his passing
this theory is actually pretty long but
if you haven't yet experienced it it's a
must read for any Harry Potter fanatic
what do you think the Dumbledore really
beer on this theory was actually
debunked by JK Rowling herself but she
did admit that they open exhilarating
new vistas of possibility but that
possibility quickly closes when you've
realized that this would mean Dumbledore
actually liked Hermione nope nope nope
the muggles won one of perhaps the most
unknown but very interesting and
extremely dark theories out there came
from reddit reddit Ursula Rita's 365
shared an interesting perspective on the
Wizarding World and said that the
Wizards already had a war with the
muggles and unfortunately the muggles
won the reddit user argues the statement
with several points in the fourth book
we learned that the Minister of Magic
was required to tell the Prime Minister
that he was bringing a dragon into the
country according to the redditor it
seems weird that this rule would exist
in the first place as Wizards do a lot
of things in front of the muggles
without involving the Prime Minister
furthermore the redditor also argues
that there seems to be a strange lack of
powerful wizards
apart from Dumbledore of course could it
be that the ministry strictly regulates
every spell and every wizard and they
ignore quite an advanced muggle
technology that could actually help them
the theory states that near the end of
the middle age the muggle trials were
more successful than the Wizards were
led to believe and that the Ministry of
Magic was created to keep the Wizards in
check after the war the government's
manipulates the Wizards to think that
they're the ones in power when really
they still have to coexist in a much
larger world
[Music]
because I have something worth living
for
[Music]
you
[Music]